mais l'une des choses que vous
m'entendez ou thierry comme je vous
entends la fois qu'elle avait
pourquoi belinda parce que kylie minogue
cahill
bonsoir travail vous parlez de france
est en fait non j'y pense mais pas s'ils
vont bon mais naturelle quoi on va se
démerder bien pourquoi on ne sait jamais
compris avec vous c'est pourquoi on dit
kylie minogue est pas kylie minogue non
c'est ce que c'est un mal un gland je
connais très bien chanté o de kylie qui
est un
supporter français
ou sait ce que ça veut dire kylie ça
veut dire [__] en route
non c'est le service public c'est une
émission culturelle de pas prendre ou en
et
servir le bouillon le boomerang ça veut
dire qu'aller en amaury gêne
bien alors oui je sais je suis pas de
votre galaxy
vous êtes australienne vous avez 33 ans
huit albums 34 single trois tournées
mondiales et avec nicole kidman vous
êtes sans doute la plus grande star
australien enfin plus grande d'influencé
les skis puis quand même pour
l'équipe i vous êtes la part la plus
grande mais sûrement une des plus
célèbres avec une seule kidman qui a
d'autres que serena en australie en
connais que vous nous
c'est vrai
kylie est ce que comme beaucoup
d'australiens vous détestez les français
à cause des essais de muro ah
ah bon vous nous aimez quand même même
s'ils ont fait sauter des bombes
atomiques à côté de chez vous vous nous
aimez quand même
arrêté aurait tu vas quand même au bout
d'un moment ça les amuse - c'est marrant
l'australien aussi il envoie une bombe
atomique chez nous bravo laurent
ça c'est du noron oui pour faire un mot
parce que oui c'est un mode auteurs
savaient qu'en fait je sais pas s'il ya
assez de poitrine pour obtenir le label
bon mode bio etc
une question de laisser
jeudi par m très strict tu peux lui
traduire mais en étant sympa quoi
problème merci belinda non she's not
really translator
quelque chose de différent
qu'est ce que je fais quand vous parlez
anglais un jeu vient couvrir de basse
voix mélodieuse la vôtre ou alors non
ils traduisent et quand je parle anglais
bon je vais faire alors donc à l'antenne
un ok i'm a nazi
corti ita de la concurrence vient alors
vous avez fait vos débuts à 11 ans vous
étiez actrice de séries télé des séries
télé formaté pour les teenagers et à 17
ans j'étais déjà une énorme star grâce à
un album qu'on a tous vu ici en france
où les netbooks mais si c'était elle
s'appelait charline c'était très chaud
les obligeant à y regarder toutes les
marques qui passait
pas puni nous plaît vous aimez regretter
comme c'est devenu star très jeune vous
avez regretté quand même ne pas être
allé plus longtemps à l'école c'est vrai
non
vous voulez apprendre maintenant
vous allez apprendre oui oui oui bien
sûr c'est pour ça que fait cette
proposition alors ensuite vous
enregistrez de locomotion et vous
choisissez une carrière de chanteuse
musique maestro
oui
[Musique]
bravo
et aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui à ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
voilà c'est le nouveau cd de kylie
minogue qui est extrait de son nouvel
album peace la peine qu'ils veulent
car les 1000 us
alors il ya un truc qui est
extraordinaire avec vous kylie c'est que
contrairement à beaucoup d'autres
starlettes des années 80 vous avez
réussi à surfer sur les modes en
changeant souvent d'image en brouillant
les pistes un peu comme madonna un peu
comme madonna vous avez été teenager's
et eden si vous allaitez underground
vous avait t il dit vous avez été pop
vous avez été dix causes étaient dix
mots
n'ont pas dit mot n'ont pas dit non
c'est vrai
je pense avoir eu de la chance
d'avoir emprunté ces différentes
personnalités au cours de ma carrière
parce que généralement vous avec une
image un petit peu monomaniaque ouais
alors aujourd'hui beaucoup de chansons
ou la linaf oui oui oui on entend que
toi veulent et
ça devient lourdingue la sicafi merci
alors qu'elle est kylie kylie pourquoi
cet album
why why this allemagne
non classé une autre émission
ouailles ses albums ouailles
quel est l'intérêt des doigts jeu
c'est mon travail où t'as pas envie de
voir où l'on en est un jour
non y est encore alors qu'at il y a les
années passant vous avez fini par
admettre complètement votre image de sex
symbol et on va le voir tout de suite
dans un clip s'appelle ski
[Musique]
moi
m
c
[Musique]
les plus
les mains
[Musique]
oui
c'est un de plus petits shorts du c'est
le plus riche du monde
d'où le short est short honneur 1
vraiment incroyable ce choc alors quelle
est l'origine
commencer venu
c'était réfléchi avant
commençait à commencer le chat richard
devais de le protéger
ipod touch et négoce c'est simplement
que s'habiller ou lave linge et puis les
souris sont rétrécis puis voilà ce que
je veux dire simplement à tout le monde
ici à toute la france d'une certaine
façon c'est qu'à 33 ans il faut pouvoir
se permettre de porter un short pareil
pas tellement pour sa 30e ressentent
mais pourrait pas le maître exemple
c'est pas jennifer lopez qui pourrait
avoir un short comme ça
christine ockrent non plus non plus je
trouvais pas même un gros cul jennifer
lopez
se dit après je vais la rencontre et la
bbc savez
c'est une boîte est changée savez dit si
tu sais non c'est pas beau de se moquer
des étrangers c'est jure et d échanger
ce nom
c'est encore pire bien alors faut dire
que vous mesurez 1 m 55 et que vous êtes
obligé pour embrasser votre fiancée de
vous mettre sur la pointe des pieds et
vous avez les jambes très musclé c'est
grâce à ça que les gens de muscler
lembras très souvent donc a été obligé à
chaque fois ci ça lui fait des
mouvements de gymnastique
alors parmi vos finances et il ya eu
michael hutchence
vous avez flashé aussi sur le candidat
du big brother du loft story anglais qui
s'appelle brian dowling
non les na waie n'ont pas de cette
manière
c'est simplement un nouveau sexuelle qui
est éteint striant est homosexuel
vous avez pas de chance là il était beau
et
simplement très marrant très sympa il
connaissait toutes vos chansons par
coeur il est chanté dans le loft anglais
un ski eric hazart
non c'est vrai c'est une icône gay d'une
audace vous savez ça vous êtes une icône
gay
fait j'ai voté pour lui j'ai un pied un
arrêt si vous avez gagné d'accord alors
il ya des moments difficiles a
évidemment dans la vie d'artiste vous
dites d'ailleurs
c'est bien de rentrer chez soi à 8
heures du matin et se voir dans la glace
normale les cheveux gras et de se dire
ah te voilà enfin j'arrive pas vous
imaginer que je veuille ou
non simplement quand je suis fatiguée
que je me sens un petit peu ordinaire
tu crois qu'elle peut être ordinaire
points wii
kylie comme vous êtes étrangères il fait
du mal vous parlait bien français mais
c'est un petit peu compliqué pour vous
belinda un ras-le-bol donc on va faire
une interview oui non merci
il y a
mais je peux pas quand vous commencez la
musique j'entends des réductions et bien
franchement bon alors interné oui non
vous devez répondre oui ou non yes or no
bien son nom robin lehner
des chiens avant thierry
si vous trompiez votre mec est ce que
vous lui diriez
à c'est très difficile elle a fait déjà
yes à pourquoi non mais j'ai pas le
droit
parce que je suis pas du tout une bonne
menteuse je sais pas faire en
y at il encore un fantasme que vous
n'ayez pas réalisé qu'un comique
which way
we animaux
n'ont étrangement pas
est-ce que vous tour ne riez dans un
film porno pour un million de dollars
2 millions de dollars
3 millions de dollars
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
expériences homosexuelles
charmeuse à
une petite année meuzac
absolument absolument je crois qu'on en
est sûre ce soir est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu des expériences à plusieurs ânes
est-ce qu'on peut aimer plusieurs fois
dans sa vie
yes
est-ce que vous accepteriez de vous
réincarner
en jennifer lopez
hier à
est ce que vous vous aimez
est-ce que vous mais
m je ne sais pas je n'ai pas
le cdc
messieurs et le single s'appelle
cadettes 1
laurent alors
en fait c'est pas moi qui le veulent les
fleurs c'est lui
non
viens de faire la bise bien
et où en toute chose et ongles
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est vrai qu'à la république est quand
même là on l'a dit est là
ça je l'aï vite tout de suite un
événement assez incroyable et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu